you know what I found out that's
actually messed up so in a court I don't
know the exact terminology but I just
found this out the other day in divorce
court a woman can claim abuse and not
actually and basically if she convinces
the jury in divorce court that she was
abused even though like it didn't have a
separate court for itself like she
basically can lie and say she was abused
and if they think she may have been like
they will still award the kids to the
mother so there's like incentive for her
to lie that the husband abused her which
in turn and women are lying about it
exactly and the other thing is that one
of my followers brought up this point
because I had that point and he said why
can't they do it's called it's like a
visitation where there's someone else a
third party has to be there so even if
he's like an abusive Dad it's kind of
like if a guy's in prison like they can
still see the dad and know who the dad
is but there's always a third party to
like protect them yeah